m
la coordination des infirmières décide
cet après midi de suspendre la grève qui
durait depuis trois semaines maintenant
le film par qui le scandale est arrivé
la dernière tentation du christ continue
de susciter les passions après les
manifestations un incendie probablement
d'origine criminelle fait dix blessés
dans une salle parisienne lancement de
l'opération drapeau blanc l'automobile
est l'armé la plus meurtrière en france
diminue tués en moyenne chaque année
antenne 2 propose un armistice pour le
week-end de la toussaint
madame monsieur bonsoir l'information de
ce dimanche soir 7 après trois semaines
de conflit la suspension de la grève des
infirmières la coordination réunis cet
après midi a décidé de poursuivre le
mouvement sous d'autres formes notamment
une grande manifestation nationale
la deuxième le 3 novembre mais cela
signifie qu'elles ne sont donc pas
satisfaite des propositions salariales
et des réformes de structure proposée
par le gouvernement pour cette
profession mais l'information
essentielle reste tout de même l'arrêt
de la grève vers shahzad te sens une
voix contre 160 seulement les
infirmières représenté par la
coordination c'est à dire la grande
majorité d'entre elles viennent de
renoncer momentanément à la grève
nationale systématique mais elle ne
baisse pas les bras pour autant leur
mouvement se poursuivra par des
débrayages ou des actions locales et par
une grande manifestation nationale le 3
novembre prochain
même si claude evin a proposé aux 170
mille infirmières une augmentation
minimale de 500 francs elle s'estime
encore lésés financièrement et surtout
juge leur statut dévalorisé et leurs
conditions de travail inadaptés ce
conflit a débuté depuis maintenant un
mois que les infirmières ont toujours
assuré
assumer leur charge de travail ont été
complètement responsable dessous de ce
mouvement
ils ont fui la force la démonstration
que ce mouvement était un mouvement
exemplaires je crois qu'aujourd'hui
elles ont besoin de faire un break
elles ont besoin de reprendre leur
souffle et 2 seront déterminés face aux
actions nouvelles qui vont être prises
je crois que nous avons besoin de 2,2 de
nouveau nous rassembler en assemblée
générale dans l'est dans les
établissements et repartir avec d'autres
perspectives
je crois que la semaine qui arrive sera
déterminante pour beaucoup de choses
dans les positions que nous adopterons
pour les jours qui viendront la
coordination nationale des infirmières
en grève et réunis depuis ce matin dans
cette salle a longtemps hésité avant
finalement de renoncer à une grève qui
dure maintenant depuis trois semaines il
faut dire que pour les infirmières ces
arrêts de travail sont coûteux même si
souvent elles ont assuré un service
minimum et si certains hôpitaux ont
décidé d'ores et déjà le paiement des
jours de grève mais ces dernières
restent mobilisés elles sont toujours
contre les propositions de claude evin y
les syndicats qui doivent rencontrer
demain le ministre de la santé devront
en tenir compte avant dé signer l'accord
quant au gouvernement après avoir
déclaré que sa tactique était de régler
les problèmes au cas par cas comme le
disait monsieur rocard il envisage
aujourd'hui par la voix de monsieur
michel durafour ministre de la fonction
publique un grand débat une grande
rencontre avec les syndicats sur le
thème de la modernisation de la grille
des salaires et de l'organisation
générale des carrières au sein de
l'administration publique en france
monsieur durafour reconnaissante au
passage dans une interview à nos
confrères de la station radio pacifique
fm qu'à titre personnel et bien il
estimait qu'il y avait bien eu
globalement une légère diminution du
pouvoir d'achat des fonctionnaires
quant à monsieur edmond maire le
secrétaire général de la cfdt invité du
forum rmc fr 3 il estime lui que c'est
le gouvernement et lui seul qui s'est
mis dans cette très mauvaise situation
si le gouvernement connaît une situation
difficile c'est qu'il s'y met
volontairement quand notre pays connaît
une croissance de trois et demi pour
cent on ne peut plus tenir les
raisonnements
du temps où la croissance était de un an
et demi pour cent quand notre pays à un
taux d'inflation de -2 3% on peut plus
nous tenir les même tonneau raisonnement
que quand ça faisait dix ou onze autres
mondiaux il faut distribuer dans mes
entrées vendues la situation a changé et
le gouvernement doit adapter sa
politique économique et sociale doit la
rééquilibrer en fonction de la nouvelle
situation sans continuer comme ça
imperturbablement comme si rien n'avait
changé
lorsqu on agresse qui est sacrée aux
yeux des hommes il faut s'attendre au
déclenchement de mécanismes aveugle
c'est ainsi s'est exprimé aujourd'hui le
cardinal lustiger ajoutant qu'il
condamnait fermement lincendie d'origine
probablement criminelle qui la nuit
dernière a ravagé un cinéma de paris qui
projetait la dernière tentation du
christ le film scandale sur la vie de
jésus
réalisé par le réalisateur italien
martin scorsese sur les dix personnes
blessés six sont encore hospitalisés ce
soir et aujourd'hui cet après midi dans
la capitale
une seule salle présente encore le film
sur les 17 qui l'avait affiché à sa
sortie et encore s'agit-il d'une
projection sous haute surveillance
jacques violle cet après midi sur les
champs elysées le seul et dernier cinéma
qui projette le film de scorsese est à
paris est sous haute surveillance après
avoir acheté son billet
chaque spectateur et fouillé des vigiles
examine très soigneusement le contenu
des saints une centaine de personnes
assistent à la projection du film par
lequel le scandale est arrivé
j'ai entendu dire en arrivant ici en
effet que la seule à les brûler et je
crois que c'était pour moi toute façon
les raisons de plus serait ce que pour
poser un acte contre l'intolérance de
devenir voir ce qu'était ce film dans
son film martin scorsese et dépeint un
christ violent envahie par le doute et
tourmenté par la tentation
à sa sortie à paris dix sept salles
projetait la dernière tentation du
christ hier soir l'une des deux
dernières au quartier latin a été
détruite par un incendie criminel selon
les premières constatations le feu
aurait été allumé avec de l'essence
répandu sur un fauteuil grâce à
l'intervention rapide des pompiers et le
petit nombre de spectateurs le cinéma a
pu être évacué en évitant le pire
la nuit dernière certains n'ont pas
hésité à empêcher par la violence que
d'autres puissent porter un jugement
ce qui est absolument inadmissible c'est
2-2 d'empêcher quiconque d'avoir accès à
une oeuvre d'art quelle qu'elle soit
qu'il s'agit d'un livre qu'il s'agisse
d'un film qu'il s'agisse de n'importe
quelle manifestation artistique l'ouaté
l'éclair j'ai vu ce film
il est vrai que ce film a de quoi
heurter les convictions des chrétiens
mais je crois qu'on peut dire plusieurs
choses premièrement dans un pays comme
le nôtre il ya liberté de création il
faut reconnaître cette liberté
deuxièmement il faut reconnaître aussi
la liberté de ceux qui sont heurtés par
cette création
la liberté de le dire mais certainement
pas de dire de façon violente
si les faits sont bien ce que nous
pensons que la nuit dernière il y a eu
crime un incendie volontaire est un
crime on ne peut pas commettre un crime
au nom du christ les autorités
religieuses ont condamné cette violence
bien avant que le film soit sur les
écrans français des croyants avaient
manifesté ouvertement leur
désapprobation d'un autre côté menaces
anonymes et violences n'ont peut-être
pas été prises assez au sérieux
aujourd'hui tout le monde dénonce
l'intolérance oui et parmi toutes les
réactions qui sont tombés en masse cet
après-midi après cette affaire j'ai
retenu sans doute la plus originale
celle de du secrétariat national à la
culture du parti socialiste qui demande
comme riposte à cet acte d'intolérance à
une chaîne publique de télévision de
diffuser le film la dernière tentation
du christ se dit fort et sans doute
demandé aussi la vie des producteurs de
ce film dans cette affaire à l'étranger
quinze jours après les sanglants
événements d'algérie le quotidien
gouvernemental pratiquement officiel el
moudjahid le combattant reconnaît qu'il
y a bien eu torture de certains
manifestants
appréhendé il dénonce également les
arrestations massives
ainsi que les jugements hâtifs qui ont
été prononcées la semaine dernière à
alger deux jours après le document
présenté par antenne 2 donc sur la
torture de manifestants en algérie cet
aveu quasi officielles montrent que le
président chadli veut gagner deux
vitesses ceux qui voudraient s'opposer
aux réformes de société qu'il a déjà
annonce bruno ledoux est le président
chadli est en train de prendre tout le
monde de vitesse c'est sur son impulsion
que la presse algérienne dénonce
aujourd'hui les tortures pratiquées à la
suite des journées d'émeutes de la
semaine dernière la torture qui n'était
plus à alger un secret pour personne
mais sur laquelle la presse
étroitement contrôlée par le
gouvernement restait jusqu'à aujourd'hui
silencieux un peu partout dans le pays
des voix s'élevaient comme celle de ses
étudiants en grève de la faim mais le
pouvoir garder le silence
il y a quelques jours nous rencontrions
huit personnes torturées
l'une d'entre elles accepté de témoigner
à visage découvert il y avait deux
salles de torture une phrase
interrogatoire de celle de torture dont
astral d'interrogatoire on l'interrogé
et on va se tourner les journées bien
évidemment une salle où on pratique
esclapes les la baignoire les chiffons
contraire tout à l'heure comme ont opéré
il y avait une salle de sodomisation
s'était nutrinautes amusé les journées
non mais qu au cours d'un entretien de
hautes personnalités algériennes parlait
alors de bavure
aujourd'hui on va plus loin le directeur
de l'agencé officielle algérienne écrit
plus rien ne sera comme avant
une phrase qui ne suffit pas car en fait
plus rien ne doit être comme avant
un sentiment partagé par un nombre
d'algériens chaque jour grandissant je
pense que les algériens ont ont conquis
en hi pay ans le prix l'indépendance
nationale mais pour ce qui est des
libertés individuelles et individuelles
évidemment c'est liberté se conquiert
avec avec le temps
le président chadli semble maintenant
vouloir aller très vite dans la voie de
l'ouverture
il sait que 26 ans après son accès à
l'indépendance l'algérie se trouve à
nouveau à la croisée de son destin
politique d'ouverture ou pas pour les
soviétiques
rien ne change vraiment dans leur vie
quotidienne c'est à dire avant tout
leurs problèmes d'approvisionnement en
revanche au niveau politique les choses
évoluent si vite que l'on a parfois du
mal à suivre ainsi monsieur gorbatchev
propose de doter son pays d'un nouveau
système constitutionnel à l'américaine
le mot n'est pas trop fort un président
qui ne serait plus une simple potiche et
qui serait élu soit directement ou par
l'intermédiaire d'un congrès et bien
senna comme à washington cela dit en
union soviétique il faut savoir
distinguer la forme du fonds gilles
rabin en juin dernier déjà
ce projet de réforme constitutionnelle
était le sujet numéro un de la
conférence du parti
aujourd'hui on aborde des vrais
problèmes la réforme des institutions
ces changements sont indispensables il
faut limiter les pouvoirs du parti
le souhait de ce délégué sera exaucé
avant la fin du mois de novembre
dès que le projet de réforme sera votée
l'an prochain le futur congrès du peuple
comprendra comme le congrès américain
une chambre des représentants et une
chambre des nationalités autrement dit
un sénat et on ne devrait plus voir à la
tribune de ce futur congrès le politburo
du parti tout entier présidait les
débats
mais des députés élus au suffrage
universel direct est à bulletin secret
des députés qui n'auront droit qu'à deux
mandats de cinq ans pas plus il y aura
plusieurs candidats pour chaque siège
est une vraie campagne électorale avec
meetings et débats contradictoires
si cette réforme est appliquée fini le
monopole du parti qui reste unique mais
qui n'a plus droit qu'au tiers des
sièges
fini aussi la langue de bois les députés
élus parleront vrai comme ce chef
d'entreprise qui en juillet dernier
avait fait basculer en un seul discours
la conférence du parti
enfin le futur chef de l'état soviétique
qui nommera le gouvernement sera élu par
les députés lui aussi à bulletin secret
et lui aussi il n'aura droit qu'à deux
mandats successifs
alors verra-t-on un jour
mikhaïl gorbatchev être obligé de faire
campagne en urss comme par exemple
michael dukakis aux états unis
en france la remet la plus dangereuse
c'est l'automobile la voiture chaque
année en moyenne dix mille personnes
meurent à bord d'une voiture c'est pour
enrayer tenter d'enrayer en tout cas
cette hécatombe qui ont qui coûte en
plus très cher à la société et que le
gouvernement s'apprête à prendre des
mesures cette semaine dit-on
draconiennes en matière de contrôle de
vitesse d'alcoolisme au volant et de
vérification obligatoire régulière des
véhicules ayant plus de quatre ans d'âge
c'est dans le même but quand n 2 a lancé
pour le week-end de la toussaint
particulièrement meurtrier chaque année
l'opération bravo blanc pour que la
route ne soit plus un champ de bataille
mille personnes meurent chaque mois sur
les routes de france par exemple au mois
de juillet il y a eu mille morts dus aux
accidents de la route
ce un chiffre fou non c'est inacceptable
vous vous rendez compte de ce que ça
fait
mille morts c'est un peu abstrait la
regarder mille morts c'est ça regardez
bien cette image c'est seule que nous
voulions d'abord vous montrer l'image de
1000 personnes qui décèdent chaque mois
sur les routes de france c'est nous
c'est vous peut-être il faudra encore
compter les blessés cette image cette
image de criminalité mais pire une image
de guerre alors à une image de guerre il
faut répondre par un geste d'armistice
de paix et ce geste c'est ils sont le
drapeau blanc
drapeau blanc pour l'armistice pour que
la guerre s'arrête sur les routes de
france du 27 octobre au 2 novembre
antenne 2 avec europe 1 et les
assurances générales de france nous
lançons un fantastique défi pour qu'il y
ait moins de morts sur les routes de
france
c'est la première fois au monde qu'on
lance un tel défi pour épargner des vies
et j'en suis sûr on va gagner images
chocs symbole d'une hécatombe
quotidienne ce matin l'opération drapeau
blanc est devenu une réalité
première étape la fabrication du
générique je crois que pour nous tous un
peu les français on voit beaucoup de
chiffres on entend beaucoup de parler de
chiffres on ne sait jamais trop ce que
ça représente réellement je crois que
faire une photo ou faire un film avec
1000 morts donc sur le terrain vraiment
c'est une image fracassante pour les
pôles publics quel résultat
attendez vous une fabuleuse ma
mobilisation qui puisse démontrer que
les gens sont capables de se
responsabiliser au détriment je veux
dire un petit peu de ces campagnes de
répression je préfère voir
personnellement des gens se motiver se
responsabiliser pour dire plus
d'accidents secondes et vous dans trois
jours les vacances de la toussaint cette
année nous espérons pouvoir réduire le
nombre d'accidents
il sait le drapeau blanc sur les routes
c'est sauver des vies c'est éviter la
souffrance mais ce résultat dépend avant
tout de chacun de vous
oui vous l'avez compris et votre manière
de participer à cette opération est
simple à partir de vendredi arborer un
mouchoir un chiffon blanc sur votre
voiture est doucement donc sur
l'accélérateur et pour vous donner un
exemple du seul problème de l'alcoolisme
au volant j'ai retenu cette dépêche
cet après-midi la nuit dernière dans le
département de la seine maritime il ya
eu un contrôle effectué par la
gendarmerie dans la seule nuit d'hier
donc de samedi 856 contrôle 77
conducteur on présentait un taux
d'alcoolémie supérieur à 0,8 g et un
automobiliste atteignait même 2,92 g et
il ya eu 26 suppression immédiate du
permis de conduire inculpé dans la
sphère de la tacc d'une caserne de la
légion étrangère encore ce qu'ils
avaient fait un tué et un blessé grave
hier elle les deux militants qui étaient
jugés à bordeaux ont été l'un condamné à
un an de prison avec sursis mais il est
resté détenu pour d'autres affaires en
cours
le second félix tomasi a été lui a
quitté un verdict qui a toutes les
chances de prolonger la trêve établie
sur l'île depuis quelques mois
maintenant
félix tomasi qui a été accueillie tout à
l'heure par plusieurs centaines de
sympathisants sur l'aéroport de bastia
agnès poids est rentré au pays a quitté
après avoir passé cinq ans et demi dans
les prisons françaises
il a bien du mal à trouver ses mots
moi je suis libre moi je suis libre
mais comment
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
prisonniers politiques qui sont en
prison on pensait que le dialogue pour
soigner encore plus loin personnellement
je le souhaite
nous sommes heureux heureux de retrouver
agraire il rentre chez lui qui va
pouvoir et densément de tags comme il
disait
enfin enfin la liberté enfin la justice
vient ne manque ni les banderoles ni les
fusils retour à bastia félix tomasi
parle à ses amis
et encore si l'heure est à la fête
mais vie si on n'oublie pas la corse ont
été ce soir les autonomistes
c'est une économie à construire et une
culture à préserver naissance officielle
d'un mouvement communiste rénovateurs
différent du parti communiste
l'événement ait lieu à vitrolles dans
les bouches du rhône aujourd'hui
monsieur claude labre a été désigné
comme coordinateur national du mouvement
et pierre juquin qui est pourtant le
plus célèbre des rénovateurs jusqu'à
présent du moins n'est pas membre de ce
nouveau mouvement nouvelle calédonie au
cours de la campagne qu'il mène
actuellement pour le non au référendum
jean marie le pen déclaré hier soir à
nantes
la question posée est un fouillis
juridique en fait il s'agit de dire si
on est oui ou non d'accord pour
l'indépendance du territoire la question
officiel je vous le rappelle au passage
est la suivante êtes vous d'accord avec
le projet de statuts mise au point en
attendant l'autodétermination dans dix
ans quant à la campagne officielle elle
démarre demain
et voici en avant première le message
télévisé réalisé par le centre
d'information civique organisme officiel
qui n'accepte pas l'idée l'abstention ou
de non participation active prônée par
le rpr rachid arhab une pub pour
savonnette un clip pour top 50 ou une
réclame pour pathé achats pas du tout
ceci est la nouvelle campagne du centre
d'information civique pour le prochain
référendum dimanche 6 novembre 1988
référendum sur la nouvelle calédonie
trois spots en noir et blanc sur fond
sonore signée haendel scènes de la vie
quotidienne sublimé par une musique qui
veut souligner l'importance du geste
électoral
on a fait rentrer la politique dans le
quotidien des françaises qu'une démarche
tout à fait nouvelle et là dessus on a
pu faire passer un message qui est le
message de responsabilisation
c'est la vocation du cic d'appeler au
vote même quand des partis politiques le
rpr cette fois ci le ps
autrefois demandent à leurs électeurs à
s'abstenir lors d'un référendum dimanche
centre d'information civique hrw lui
dans création dans la polémique
politique
ce jour-là vous voterez oui non ou blanc
aucun gouvernement
aucune assemblée personne ne prendra
cette décision à votre place une société
dont la morale fous l'camp
est une société qui se condamne à mort
et à partir du moment où l'abstention
est la signification même du désintérêt
qui on peut avoir pour la vie de la
nation
c'est extrêmement bas parce que il
pourrait aller plus loin au cul payer
leurs impôts ou qui ont aussi une pu
respecter le code de la route ce qu'ils
font en grande partie d'un souhait nous
arrivons à une période où la campagne
contre l'abstention c'est une espèce de
campagne d'évangélisation civique
la politique ne se vend pas la politique
s'explique message clair mais le support
image risque de dérouter quelque peu la
plume au service de la lutte contre les
abstentions atteindra-t-elle sa cible
réponse le 6 novembre
économie l'espagne a décidé au milieu de
la semaine écoulée qu'il était urgent
d'attendre pour choisir entre les trois
projets de tgv et trains à grande
vitesse qui leur sont proposés la
société française alstom est toujours
favorite mais les entreprises allemandes
et japonaises demeure en course
le prétexte invoqué la décision
espagnole de normaliser l'écartement de
ces voies ferrées qui reste il faut
savoir différent de celui de ses
partenaires européens
cela dit entre la sncf et les français
donc et les chemins de fer espagnols une
autre affaire n'est toujours pas réglée
il s'agit d'une gare franco espagnol
installé au beau milieu des pyrénées à
canfranc très exactement pour les
spécialistes
côté espagnol elle fonctionne côté
français les faire mais visiblement on
n'est pas décidé à ouvrir et cela malgré
la campagne menée à madrid
valérie fournier un signal ferroviaire
rouillées des rails loyers dans la
végétation
c'est tout ce qu'il reste de cette ligne
international qui fut jusqu'en 1970 la
seule à traverser le coeur des pyrénées
depuis 18 ans le train peau saragosse ne
passe plus c'est du combat
oh là là sous les yeux c'est le point de
l'estanquet à peine 50 m à reconstruire
un débit total qui s'élève à 142
millions de francs
autant dire rien la rupture ce fut le
très banal accident d'un train de
marchandises côté français la sncf n'ait
jamais voulu entreprendre de travaux
résultat la guerre internationale de
canfranc est à l'abandon
seul sujet calix eux travaillaient dans
ses 220 m de bâti ce chef de guerre
pendant quinze ans sans voir venir de
train quel sujet avait pas de thème
puisqu'il n'arrivait pas alors je veux
sauver ricard sur le pommeau là-bas ou
quelquefois vraiment il y faisait froid
souvent d'ailleurs j'ai perdu ma
casquette à la banque ou de vannes qui
est parti dans leur frigo aragón mais
que voulez-vous il fallait attendre les
quarts aussi de quoi être désolé pour un
chef de gare
surtout que côté espagnol sur l'autre
qu'est le train de madrid et de
saragosse
celui arrivant une activité bien sûr
réduite depuis ses 18 ans de rupture la
population de canfranc est tombé de 3000
à 700 habitants c'est qu'on veut surtout
c'est que avoir le contact avec la
france
c'est obligatoire pour nous et eon ont
pris ont pris la possibilité de la rue
rpr pourtant français espagnol
s'entendait bien aussi être le dernier
lors de la création de la ligne
si le trafic était faible en 1970
aujourd'hui à l'aube de l'europe de 92
est en plein essor économique
les espagnols font de la réouverture de
cette ligne un véritable enjeu il
annonce pouvoir assurer un million de
tonnes par an de marchandises une
estimation contestée par la sncf les
études sont concordantes pour dire qu'il
n'ya aucune rentabilité possible à une
réouverture
bien entendu si une collectivité où
l'état a estimé que la ligne la
réouverture de la ligne est un service
public indispensable
la question serait tout autre mais là
aussi les étudiants ont été menées à ma
connaissance non pas actuellement abouti
la convaincre les élus pas rentable dit
paris un refus qui n'a aucun écho dans
cette vallée où les habitants français
comme espagnol rêve déjà aux tgv à 1800
mètres d'altitude
un rêve surtout un espoir de
désenclavement l'ouragan johann qui
s'est abattue sur l'ensemble de
l'amérique centrale est particulièrement
le costa rica et le nicaragua a fait des
centaines de milliers de sans abri des
victimes heureusement en nombre moins
important qu'on ne pouvait le craindre
en raison des mesures de sécurité qui
avait été prise à temps par les
autorités
thierry calmette
le cyclone jo-ann vient de ravager le
nicaragua sur 350 km nous laissant ces
images tristement familière de la presse
cyclone 14 morts cent quarante disparus
et surtout trois cent mille sans abri
l'oeil de johan a frôlé la capitale
managua à moins de 25 kilomètres avant
de se perdre dans le pacifique une
chance l'intensité des rafales de vent
et de pluie a été plus faible que prévu
dès samedi les autorités sandiniste
faisait évacuer 70 mille habitants de
managua ainsi que les populations
d'autres villes côtières où vivent 80 %
des 3 millions de nicaraguayens il
semble que je n étais plus
particulièrement meurtrier sur la côte
est
la ville de bluefields 25000 habitants
seraient aux trois quarts des truites
difficile d'en savoir plus les
communications sont interrompus un peu
partout en europe et notamment en france
l'aide internationale s'organise pour
répondre aux besoins de 300 milles sans
abri du nicaragua un bilan provisoire
on peut s'attendre here on a aussi le
droit d'être choqués ou du moins de
s'interroger quand on constate les
moyens qui ont été mis en oeuvre pour
tenter de sauver deux baleines qui reste
coincé sous la banquise de l'alaska
alors qu'il est si difficile de se
courir les hommes restent les faits les
secours les plus modernes continuent de
converger vers l'alaska afin de
permettre aux baleines de regagner le
plus rapidement possible la haute mer
obc reste le plus gros avion militaire
au secours du plus gros animal sur terre
ce galaxy la preuve tangible de
l'intérêt du président reagan pour le
sort des deux s'est tassée qui se
débattent maintenant depuis deux
semaines pour survivre dans ses soutes
du matériel lourd pour les opérations de
sauvetage
mais sur la banquise les autres presque
à mains nues continue pour découper ces
cubes de glace parfois une simple gaffe
25 qui nous inondent déjà tronçonné 24
au 24 bouffée d'oxygène qui ont permis
aux bonnettes et crosby re de parcourir
moins d'un kilomètre et l'espoir est
encore à six kilomètres de là
les scientifiques ont en effet décelé
une grande fissure naturel cette
fracture pourrait être le début du
chenal de la liberté pour les cétacés
définitivement abandonné l'idée de faire
tracter les brise glaces ben & co par un
hélicoptère progression trop lente
les jours voire les heures sont comptées
si les deux baleines n'ont pas recouvert
la liberté d'ici la semaine prochaine
l'urss a promis l'aide d'un de ses
navires brise-glaces l'amiral makarov
qui se trouve à moins de 500 km au nord
de barrow la solidarité des hommes
existe quand même la preuve
terre des hommes qui fêtait cette
semaine ses 25 ans d'existence a choisi
un moyen original de faire connaître son
action aux enfants un membre de
l'organisation venus du mali a décidé de
faire une tournée des écoles françaises
afin d'expliquer concrètement l'intérêt
de l'aide humanitaire josé blanc la
pierre dans la banlieue de reims le cs
collet guillard 14 heures comme chaque
lundi la cinquième h
à cours de géographie mais aujourd'hui
une surprise l'attend je viens du mali
qui se trouvent en afrique plus
précisément à l'afrique de l'ouest
ibrahim kéita raconte les touareg le
sahel les vents de sable et la menace
des criques et puis les actions de terre
des hommes motopompes bassin pour
stocker l'eau expérience pour fixer les
dunes dans un cours pas comme les autres
les enfants veulent en savoir plus ce
soit maintenant vous qui me posaient des
questions
le long terme et l'objectif de terre des
hommes
pour l'expliquer l'association m
s'adresser aux enfants un public qui
reçoit le message cinq sur cinq
cultiver va dans les supermarchés de
salars que son musée de cultiver
eux-mêmes pour
pouvoir se nourrir faut pas lui donner
un poisson parce que s'ils ne le mangera
puis après il y aura une nourriture faut
bien apprendre à pêcher comme ça quand
il voudra manger bailly il saura quoi
faire aider les populations démunies à
se prendre en charge
un but qui distingue terre des hommes d
autres mouvements de solidarité on a
tendance à peu à nous montrer le tir
monde comme une espèce de multiplication
d'estomac vie qui nous tendent la main
pour faire la charité alors que le
tiers-monde c'est un petit peu autre
chose on a appris en 25 ans que le
tiers-monde mais aussi des gens qui sont
spécialement qui ont une conscience
sociale politique et qui savent
s'organiser furent des choses simplement
ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on les aide
une mode une solidarité pour les aider à
faire ce qu'ils ont envie
avant de quitter ibrahim la cinquième
marche décident d'échanger des lettres
avec une classe de thiennes cours près
de tombouctou
que de choses à raconter ce soir à la
maison l'arrière par journaliste je fais
aussi sport débuts demain des
internationaux de tennis de bercy que
vous pourrez suivre en exclusivité sur
antenne 2 et fr3 avec dès mardi le choc
le comte mcenroe henri leconte qui a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à se faire
pardonner par le public français
christian qu'il est eh bien henri
leconte vient de s'entraîner sur le
central de l'open de bercy pendant une
heure et demie avec patrick mcenroe le
frère de john mcenroe henry vous allez
très bien servi au cours de cet
entraînement mais j'ai très bien sa vie
comme si j'ai retrouvé de bonnes
sensations ici sur ce central ça fait
toujours plaisir
j'ai toujours bien joué ici je pense que
moi il faut travailler maintenant jouer
john mcenroe c'est pas une tâche facile
il va falloir bien bien travaillé c'est
ce que j'ai fais tout ton cette semaine
est bon ben j'ai une carte à jouer et
puis de façon j'ai rien à perdre oui
alors vous ne l'avez jamais battu john
mcenroe soffin d'exhibition comment
allez vous de jouer tactiquement
tactiquement je veux jouer bon comme pas
comme bilan des restaurants du coup en
jouant mon jeu mon jeu est basé sur
l'attaqué ayant j'espère que je vais
servait comme j'ai servi ce soir une
bonne volée et surtout est très très
rapide sur les jambes parce que bon mc
enroe un jeu il joue très très vite
et contrairement aux joueurs ils jouent
d'avant en arrière et ça c'est un jeu
très difficiles à pouvoir contrôler il
faut être bien sur les joues est-ce que
vous avez la sensation henry d'avoir
besoin de reconquérir le public parisien
je pense que j'ai besoin surtout de
gagner des matchs ils ont besoin de me
voir gagner des tournois des couples et
des matchs aussi je pense que ils ont
besoin de vous
un grand tennis le tennis que j'ai
produit à roland garros je pense que je
vais faire le maximum et ça va être un
superbe hommage à dire maintenant c'est
de on est deux joueurs qui sont très
spectaculaire à voir jouer j'espère que
ça sera notre voie là espérons nous
aussi le rapport du tiercé qui se
courait cet après midi pour terminer ce
journal vous allez le voir s'inscrire
sur votre écran 11 4 8 et ça rapporte
2410 francs il y avait un quarter
également vous rajoutez le 19 et ça
rapporte plus mais vous avez joué plus
50 54 1696 francs et 60 centimes que
vous ramassez c'est la monnaie voilà ce
journal est terminée tout à l'heure vous
retrouverez et avec tout pour les
dernières informations de ce dimanche
tout de suite après le journal les
prévisions météo avec josé blanc
lapierre et puis demain premier rendez
vous 6h45 télématin et demain soir à 20h
vous retrouver ici même christine
ockrent je vous souhaite à tous une
excellente semaine bonsoir
oh